Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
It's automatically going to
Yeah, that's weird
Try to explain more what happens
I think maybe
I might have
A VPN on or something
For some reason it's
I'm just putting in
Intermine.com and it's going straight to
The German
Version of the website
Like it's
So, hold on, maybe let me
I'll stop recording and I'll just switch that
I'll make sure that's not
I don't use
Edge very often
So
I think maybe
Just switch
Okay
Let me just try it again
No, it seems to be
Okay, what is going on?
Sorry again
Try to explain more
Because
The problem will be
Put it from our voice
From transcriber
What we're saying
And what's the problem?
It will be easier for AI to navigate
Where was the problem?
What's the problem?
On what stage?
So, I'm
Going on to Microsoft Edge
I'm putting in
Intermined
Dotcom
And
When I press
Enter
It's forwarding me
To the German version
Of the website
But I think
That maybe
I might have
VPN on
Or something
But it was not
Doing this before
Which is
Or maybe
I tried the same
Theme
I opened
Microsoft Edge
Put it
Intermined
Dotcom
Pressed enter
And
German
Version
Of website
Opened for me
It did as well
I've just gone
Into the website
And
On
At the
Toolbar
At the top
There's a
Switch language
And I've just
Switched it to
English
And it seems
To have worked
Same on my site
Okay
Press
Sign in
Button
And
Tell me
What you're
Seeing
Try to
Register
On your
Email
So
From
The
From the
Main
Homepage
I'm not
Seeing a
Sign in
Or register
Button
There's
Join
Meeting
Or
Open
App
Perhaps
I would
Go
Open
App
If I
Had to
Guess
I think
Potentially
Because I
Already have
An
Account
Logged
In
Yeah
Try to
Log out
Let me
Okay
I see
So
Now
It's
Sign in
That's
A lot
Clearer
That was
Just
Pult
Okay
Understand
Any
Language
Sign in
To
Create
Your
Intermined
Account
Let me
Just
Go
Okay
I'm
Just
Putting
In
My
Email
In
The
Email
Form
There's
Also
A bunch
Of
Different
Options
That
Are
Very
Useful
Friendly
Like
Google
And
Microsoft
I've
Already
Used
Google
And
It
Worked
Perfectly
Fine
On
Both
The
Website
And
The
Phone
Gonna
Go
Continue
With
Email
Okay
Pop
Up
Says
They've
Sent
Me
An
Email
Do
You
Want
Me
To
Go
Into
My
Gmail
Or
Is
It
Just
I
Like
Have
The
Email
Has
Come
Through
I
Can
Confirm
It
With
Open
Your
Gmail
Try
To
Open
This
Email
And
Link
If
It's
Successful
Say
If
Not
Tell
Me
What
You
See
And
After
A
Few
Minutes
Try
To
Open
This
Link
Again
It
Should
Be
Expired
And
Was
There
You
See
Okay
I've
Just
Got
It
In
My
Email
Very
Simple
My
Code
With
Your
Intermined
Sign-in
Code
Expires
In
Minutes
Or
Click
The
Button
To
Sign-in
Directly
I'm
Going
To
Click
The
Button
To
See
If
That
Works
Put
In
My
Verification
Code
And
I'm
Signed
In
Okay
Try
To
Change
Password
For
Account
All right
Let's
Go to
Where
My
Account
Is
In
The
Bottom
Left
Three
Dots
Documentation
Dottom
Hmm
Toggle
Theme
Is
The
Okay
I
Cannot
Seem
To
Find
Maybe
In
Settings
Maybe
I'm
Looking
In
The
Wrong
Place
I
See
User
That's
My
Name
Avatar
Email
I'm
Not
Seeing
A
Password
Anywhere
I'm
Not
Exactly
Sure
Where
I'm
To
Change
Passwords
Yeah
I
Don't
See
Anywhere
Where
I
Can
Change
Password
If
I
Just
Go
To
Dedicated
Support
So
This
Seems
Like
A
Okay
Perhaps
I
Should
Go
To
Help
First
That
Seems
Maybe
A
Bit
More
I'll
Just
Ask
How
Do
I
Change
My
Password
Oh
Okay
Intermine
Does
Not
Use
Passwords
For
Email
Logins
You
Receive
A
One
Time
Six
Digit
Code
In
Your
Inbox
Each
Time
To
You
Signed
To
You
Use Google
Microsoft
Or
SSO
Your
Authentication is handled by these providers
Okay
So I've just used the AI assistant to help me try and change my password
Turns out I do not have a password nor do I need one and it's explained that quite clearly very quickly
Um
Yeah okay
All right
Try to log out and sign in and put the button to restore password or forgot the password
Okay
Uh
To see with
What should I be signing in with because when I sign in with email it doesn't require a password
Should I sign in with Google or with SSO
Yes
And so how you will log in next time you're so you're receiving a just one-time code for login
Without password
Yes when when you use the work email it seemed to only ask me for a one-time code and not a password
Yes
Mm-hmm okay let's pass the step
Uh try to delete your account if you'll find any button of it
Okay
Let's see
I'm just logging back in
Okay
Back my email again
Yeah
The email is very quick
Signing in
I'll leave
All right signed in
Go back in
Okay let me go to settings
I'll just do a quick test to make sure I see
Delete account
Permanently delete your account and all associated data
This action cannot be undone
A very clear red text
The
Use of the trash can
Kind of a use of a universal symbol
Very easy to understand
Very clear statement that it is permanent
Going to click on delete
Another warning pops up
This is good just to make sure anyone doesn't misclick on it
Type your email to confirm
Try this again
Actually I wonder if you can copy and paste this from here
I don't know if that would be a big thing
You can
Gives you a big red warning
This will permanently delete your account and all data including meetings
Messages, files, team ownership and subscription
This cannot be undone
Very clear instructions
Click delete permanently
Okay
Taken me out
Seemingly deleted it
And then if I try to
Sign in with that again
Okay
Let's go to my Gmail
Sign in again
It seems like I've still been able to sign into my account
I'm not sure if it's created a new one
Or if it's
The same one
I mean it seems to be
I think maybe I would have to sign in
The same?
Yeah I'm not sure
I think maybe I would have to sign in
A different sign in method
Also I didn't check last time
But it doesn't allow you to
Click delete permanently
Until you've entered
Your email address
I'm just going to enter something in there
And then try and delete permanently
And see if it works
Okay email does not match
Good
That's all working
Try it again
Actually maybe I should
Okay let me create something
First
Can I create
Okay
So this will be able to tell
If when I delete my account
And log in
If it's creating a new account
Or signing back in
Delete account
Okay
Delete permanently
Okay let's try signing back in
With the exact same thing
And see if my daughter
Is still there
Email
The code sending is very quick
This is very seamless
Okay
So it seems like it does
Actually delete your account
The stuff that I added before
Isn't there
So that does seem to be working
Okay
What next
So in the instructions
Maybe I should register through
It does say to register through
SSO or Google
If available
Would you like me to try
Registering through
Google
To see if that
Changes the outcome
Or actually
I'll do it to see
If I can
I think there's no reason
To try with Google
Or with separate email
I just
I tried the same thing
Just to log in
Through
Through my email
Without
Google SSO
I logged in my account
And I see
On the settings
That I already have
Avatar
So I logged in
On the same account
As from the Google
Or from email
By the same email ID
So it's the same
Okay okay
I was just gonna check
Yeah
When I try to sign in
With Google
I don't think it
Like I still have no option
To change a password
Because we didn't get to that
Okay
I'm deleting my account again
Alright
I think
We're all good with that
Do we want to move on
To step three
Or
Yeah let's save
Our recording
Yeah
Продолжение следует...